[Applause]
welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse this is Philip Molina is there
glass available eating here with the big
question welcome back to new rockstars
I'm Erik Bosse this philemon yone this
is the big question folks it's our
weekly Q&A show but we're gonna answer
your biggest questions but all things
nerdy demure 4-cyl oh my god what says
everything you do and the wind or the
the sonic boom that's out the fire
liquefied the organs of everyone inside
they can outlive all of us if we don't
need them I got robbed as a child
oh you're able to tell based on the
sound what body part has been tight you
can't your meat pushes back into each
other till it reaches tell me more about
my meat it's a pip rip absolutely we'll
find out about that later in the show
there's that time that you punch me in
the face we're both two records
difficoult I'm gonna shove this in me
like the kid it's good I gotta go to
therapy again how much did you start
drinking before we started I won't tell
we are getting creatively more drunk as
the show goes this will be called you
know nuts I'm all from sexy vamos no man
here I want to be tucked into my grave
gently like that I can't wait to do this
more and more you drink at work yeah see
you next